Kourtney Kardashian and Scott disick's
Son Mason celebrates his bar mitzvah
it's a beautiful thing Mr sells E.T
Mason who turned 13 earlier this month
marked the Milestone over the weekend
with his family by his side first a
dinner together with a party right after
at a nightclub in West Hollywood a
lavish celebration for the bar mitzvah
boy who's half Jewish on his father's
side being in Temple feels great it
really does
so I got you two matching ones oh
seriously I could give one to my son yo
I gotta tell you just to get my feet wet
again just to be back in the temple
really feels good and it seems Mason's
Bar Mitzvah which is a coming-of-age
ritual in Judaism when just as Scott
wanted a swords tell us ET quote Scott
took the lead on planning everything
Andy was so happy with how it turned out
he was really proud of Mason and glad to
be celebrating this Milestone with him
at the end of the day I mean you just
want to be happy you want to be content
as for the guest list Mason siblings
Penelope and Rain were of course there
along with his cousin Northwest and Kim
and Khloe Kardashian and Kylie Jenner
and his grandma Kris Jenner I'm so lucky
because we all live very close to each
other so I get to see my grandchildren
very often like every day so it's the
best as for Mason's parents court and
Scott who ended their relationship in
2015 after dating on and off for 10
years the two were focused on making
sure the birthday boy enjoyed his
celebration our source says Courtney and
Scott were very friendly with each other
and talked and hung out at the party I
mean I think you just got a figure out
really what's important to you at the
end of the day the source adds that
Mason's Party included dessert trucks
and all of the guests danced and enjoyed
themselves proving just that Coco shared
a few photos from the event with her
nieces Penelope and North
the good American founder wrote in the
caption Mazel Tov Mason the girls and I
attempted to take some pics we all want
to be cute over here okay on Wednesday
Court wished Mason and his little
brother Reign who was born on the same
day five years after him a happy
birthday on Instagram she rode alongside
the sweet post December 14th one of the
best days of my life twice and forever
my birthday boys
[Music]
thank you